justin bieber told fans who were waiting
outside of his new york city apartment
to greet him to
scram so on saturday tick tock user
vanessa fbx posted a now viral video of
the pop star
walking from his car to his apartment
building where a group of fans were
outside the entrance asking for a hug
and photos but bieber politely declined
their invitation and instead reminded
fans
he's human too justin hi justin
can
and i don't appreciate you guys
you know at the end of the night when
you come home and you want to relax
that's my space
oh my god yeah so this isn't the first
time justin has expressed his
displeasure
for lack of privacy to eager fans back
in october of last year the singer
called
out fans waiting outside his home on his
instagram story saying
how do you convince yourself it's not
completely inappropriate and
disrespectful to wait outside my home to
gawk
stare and take pictures as i walk into
my apartment this is not a hotel
it's my home oh my goodness should fans
respect bieber's privacy
yeah so what do you so what do you what
do you think on on i actually thought he
was really polite about it
i thought i thought he was so polite
look at that yeah
oh my god it's the canadian politeness
for me
that was the best way to say beat it it
was just so canadian like i loved it um
i just think after that entire speech
and that tick tock video that fan
still asked for a picture which tells me
she didn't hear a damn thing she didn't
even she was just like oh my god he's so
handsome
i don't even care what he's saying i
just want this picture i think waiting
outside of someone's home is loitering
it's very creepy i know that some of
these fans are really young and they
have the best intentions
and they really do spend hours of their
time waiting for their favorite star but
like
that's only cute when you're at a
concert or waiting for tickets and like
showing your love in that way i think
that there needs to be boundaries and if
you really love
bieber you'll at least respect his home
yeah so vanessa's saying give justin a
break fans need to give the pop star a
freaking break
uh lindsay's saying i'm not a fan of
bieber however i understand where he's
coming from when strangers are waiting
outside of his home
it's creepy um
and uh yeah then people are commenting
on on the the fan
saying uh she looked shocked b being
saying uh she definitely wanted to cry
now joey's saying he can afford to buy a
thousand acres in the middle of nowhere
uh yet he chooses to live there um
carlos and yes fans go way too far with
stalking
um and uh and asking for too much
chrissy's saying i don't blame justin at
all on this one you really should
respect his home and he was so
respectful about it he's really
matured i would agree with that as well
because here's the thing i think at the
end of the day he knows
these fans are just excited he's been
dealing with this since he's a kid right
um but unfortunately and you know this
something happens when
uh someone becomes a celebrity or
they're on tv or
that whole human element kind of goes by
the wayside and people put them up on
this kind of larger than life
scenario and i really i know this sounds
silly but i've seen it time and time
again
i really think people forget that
they're human beings and have feelings i
really do
i think they're like love and admiration
for them
um really takes over and i think they
think they're being a really good fan
i think a lot especially when you're
young i think people feel like that's
like proving
like how much they love you but it's
like oh yeah
no so um it's unfortunate yet that she
didn't listen
i think she probably went home and
probably thought about it um
but yeah that's i thought he did such a
good job and honestly sure he can
afford to go anywhere but he should be
able to live where he wants
exactly no totally well said and i think
sometimes music and movies
people have such emotional attachments
to them because it really helps them
through phases in their lives and
that they get attached to that actor to
that you know singer so i can see that
being
a situation but i just have to give
kudos to bieber because
he could have easily had security escort
those fans out
or you know yelled at them or did he
could have handled this
different way he didn't have to make
himself the bad guy or the polite nice
guy
however you want to look at it he didn't
even have to address them they could
have been removed by security a long
time ago
so you know kudos to him i think the way
he handled it was very canadian
and i am proud no i agree with you and
on facebook too diane's saying he handed
it well i worry that it will uh end up
like
uh john lennon and they won't leave him
alone addie
let's be honest would have started
screaming and or swaying so bieber
handled that
real well i agree oh yes
i agree